yeah some people got tossed out they
actually hit the hotline so let me play
this for you
oh
um
how's the food it was pretty cool I went
to smoke I'm coming back and uh they're
trying to get my how uh my husband off
because he said something it is gone
he was like really excited to see if
Dearborn because we just moved to
college time and he was excited but like
it was not fair and I'm about to do
House of Food thank you
okay and so that she hit the hotline
that lady and she's probably she sounds
so hopped up on something she sounds you
know dang you know Slovakian or
something
you know she sounded like she just you
know she's out there she might be
growing uh cabbages or something in her
neck you know she sound like she's
really doing you know something's going
on
she sounds you know and that and that's
when you you know you're when you've
been drinking too much when you sound
like you are uh suddenly you're
bilingual
now I'm saying I never been so [__] up
that I'm talking in Cantonese I never
been that tanked out
but she called and that wasn't it she
said it wasn't fair
uh and then this call hit the hotline as
well hey Theo it's your boy Greg I love
you too the mean wife got kicked out of
your show kind of the House of Blues I
don't know why
I think your boy Drake your boy he looks
like a jerk was hating on
that's cool and look I guess he ran into
somebody that looks like Drake and they
have a lot I mean I'll be like this
honestly about 10 of America looks like
Drake these days and it is a little bit
alarming more come on now
I want to let you know that it's all
good and I love it but it's kind of
messed up because we got kicked out for
no reason
I was buying Transit bar I'll be hitting
that
fear
you're watching it
share is okay and there you go he's
getting all tanked out he's almost dang
you know he sounds like he might be from
Mogadishu or somewhere
and I think some of the thing is man you
just
I don't like what are you gonna do if
you that tanked up at a show you can't
enjoy that my Hunger
and that's the only reason if you know
if people if it gets out of hand and
otherwise man it was a joy
you know but that dude look he called in
himself
bro this ain't you know and people
already in Louisiana it's a wild time
when you do a show in Louisiana
dude they had somebody in a crowd
yelling defense the whole time
people don't know what's going on
some [__] was yelling when's the coin
toss
you know some people just they never
been to a comedy show
one lady asked where the signups were at
I said yeah we ain't doing all of that
people just it's it's an acquired
experience and you had you know and once
people go to Comedy over time they get
the hang of it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one